BRIAN GRANT: Hi,
I'm Brian Grant.
I'm a Principal
Engineer at Google.
I'm also a founding member of
the CNCF Technical Oversight
Committee.
I just came off of a Q&A
panel for the CNCF TOC.
The TOC's job is to curate the
set of projects in the CNCF
to make sure that
they help advance
the cloud-native mission
of the foundation,
and also to help those
projects succeed.
So that latter part,
helping the project succeed,
is an increasing
focus of the TOC
as we try to figure
out how to identify
what services the projects
need from the foundation
and how we can help the projects
attract new contributors
and maintainers.
If you look at the
set of projects,
like Kuberetes, Prometheus,
Fluentd, GRPC, OpenTracing
and OpenTelemtry is a
recent project that Google's
been involved with, that
portfolio of projects
is really about helping
operators, users,
developers manage applications
with high velocity at scale
predictably and safely with
minimal amounts of toil.
So as we look towards the
future with additional projects
that we might take
into the foundation,
we'll be looking for projects
to fill gaps in that portfolio
where users,
operators, developers
really need a solution that
fits with the other projects
we have.
So if you're interested in
talking about those topics
and you're here at Keep Time,
come by the Google Cloud booth.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]